I never touched
an award, an Oscar.
So this is the first time
touching an Oscar.
It's ripping my Band-Aid off.
You know what I mean?
This is amazing.
I didn't realize how heavy
this would be.
Reminds me of holding my baby
daughter, it has a similar feeling
Well my daughter has grown up,
And she saw me,
as her father,
Always being busy
performing on stage
in all these various theaters.
And she was trying to understand
what her father was doing.
But I think finally, now
she's able to witness this
and come along on my journey
and come along on this
wild ride with me.
So now she sees her
father's success
from really from scratch.
And I think my daughter
finally feels proud of her dad.
She's a CODA in real life,
a child of a deaf adult,
she has two deaf parents.
You know what I mean?
It's really cool and it's
such a special moment.